qu'est ce que ça fait pour un gars comme
toi qui es un gars d'ici qui connaît
l'histoire de cette équipe là qui a vu
tout le cheminement qui a été fait
qu'est ce que ça fait maintenant d'être
à la porte quelque chose de grand si tu
demandes quand j'étais jeune j'ai pensé
à ça jamais et pas juste où je suis mais
où le club il est le stade qui est plein
il ya du monde qui nous suivent
j'ai vu comment le soccer a grandi ici
je suis très content très fier de
pouvoir être un entraîneur maintenant en
charge de cette équipe et tous ces
champions qu'on a derrière des vêtements
il a transformé les choses a depuis
qu'il est arrivé
on a parlé beaucoup c'est ce qui a eu un
effet drogba ça c'est clair
moi je pense aussi en fait je suis
convaincu qu'il ya aussi un effet biello
est ce que toi tu peux mettre des mots
sur ses petits fils actuellement oui à
la le grand effet drogba ça c'est sûr
pour moi je voulais l'assemblée ce
groupe je savais qu'on avait des joueurs
talentueux et maintenant comment je
communique comment je prépare les choses
et à travers ça j'espère qu'ils vont
observer mes idées et mes méthodes lan à
des premières choses que j'ai dit c'est
il faut vous exprimer sur terrain vous
êtes capable et j'ai donné cette
confiance
pascal aff à sion n'est capable de
partager cette confiance on va être
mieux
ce que tu peux nous donner un exemple de
ce que tu dis aux joueurs pour les
convaincre que tu as raison qu'il faut
qu'on te suivent que c'est la bonne
mentalité c'est la tienne qu'est ce que
tu leur dis exactement
la première chose j'ai dit moi je suis
pas un magicien je vais pas vous faire
des meilleurs joueurs ça c'est votre
travail
moi je suis là pour vous guider je suis
là pour essayer de faire sortir vos
forces
je suis convaincu qu'un entraîneur chef
a aussi beaucoup d'insécurité on veut
être sûr de passer le bon message de
faire faire les bons entraînements
comment on fait pour être en confiance
et faire grandir cette confiance et
faire en sorte que les joueurs nous
fasse confiance pour respirer beaucoup
quand des grands souffle ça c'est sûr et
ça c'est la vie d'un entraîneur
questionne tout c'est pour ça on a un
staff qui est à côté de moi qui essayait
de faire des choses un peu plus clair et
ça c'est important mais c'est normal
pour la vie d'un entraîneur tu essaies
de d'avoir tout fait pour les mettre
dans les meilleures conditions
quel est le message que tu donnes à tes
joueurs pour ce match contre toronto un
match-suicide mes mots clés ça va être
la concentration parce que ce serait un
match difficile et je vais me baser sur
sa dette le conte santé dans tous les
moments on peut pas être surpris quand
le sifflet
commence alors pour moi c'est cette
concentration pendant 90 minutes
merci beaucoup ma roue et bonne chance
merci